you see him  got him  reloading i'm reloading  i know i saw him  he's pushing he's pushing you  i'm trying to help you no i know  they're both pushing  that one there we go yep i assisted  he's right there pika right in front  [Applause]  double kill  team george has been sacked  get [ __ ] [ __ ]  good job pika  you got 10 seconds  you flattened team hal struggle's over  take a minute you just [ __ ]  he's right here  got him  there's other guys right here  dude i hated him dude because like it  doesn't like in other games it [ __ ] up  your recoil  alright i got that guy all right they're  pushing left they're pushing that  i got him on the right  that one i well bang them  good [ __ ] good [ __ ]  [Applause]  one more life  where did he shoot me from he's on the  he's on the other side of us  in that room god damn it i wish you  didn't okay  yeah  you did it oh